[Musique]
on
c'est la droite qui nous regarde et vous
laissez pas prêt
encore jamais vraiment maximum est
parfait alors rêvons
amusez-vous de ma gueule
c'est à verdun
rallye qu'est ce que tu as dit là je
suis toujours producteur pendant encore
trois ans ici ces nouveaux chapeaux et
moi avec ce produit par mois ce produit
parfois
bah oui c'est moi qui la case
attend-on non mais c'est quoi l'adresse
france veille si c'est quoi je change
tout le pré-générique général à la cause
de toi c'est un leader
les chéris je vous le dis on devait
faire un truc et je vais faire
complètement notre pourquoi parce que il
ya un instant il s'est passé quelque
chose de très grave il ya une personne
ici qui a voulu me [ __ ] dehors de ces
huit de leurs maux mais moi je connais
mon épouse et moi sur le côté séries qui
l'attend la frontera sur m6 aux
alentours de 21h 10 juste avant vous
regardez benjamin castaldi qui sera là à
ma place c'est ce que pendant deux jours
je ne serais pas là je suis voilà je
vous le dis en fête religieuse je vais
me re source et sur ma personne
[Musique]
du célèbre jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raymond
c'est à vous
[Musique]